bonsoir il dans la tête merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france jour
particulier on l'a dit en belgique un
mini défilé pour commémorer la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale et ses
festivités est ce qu'elle représente
pour vous un risque en cette période de
crise sanitaire ce qu'il ya lieu de
s'inquiéter
alors pour l'instant on n'a pas de
risque liés ou fait elle-même qui ont
été extrêmement limités par contre
divers foyers qui se sont réveillés dans
le pays c'est la première fois depuis
qu'on a des consignes et pose
effectivement un problème qui est
préoccupant sans être dramatique
le pays a tout de même pris des
précautions pour éviter les
rassemblements pour vous est-ce que
c'est suffisant alors pour l'instant il
ya un certain nombre de comités qui se
sont réunis qui ont référé leur avis
vers le conseil national de sécurité qui
doit se dérouler jeudi et les fort
probable de consignation de sécurité
prenne des mesures supplémentaires soit
général soit localisé pour éteindre les
petits incendies mais significatif qui
sont arrivés à différents endroits pour
vous à quoi doit-on attribué c'est comme
vous dites ces petits incendies
c'est un relâchement de la part des
belges qui ont peut-être envie de se
libérer de ses contraintes
comme dans beaucoup de pays d'ailleurs
mais tout est fait comme je le voyais il
ya quelques instants de reporter à ce
concert dans la france on a des
problèmes liés à des rassemblements
familiaux ou avec des amis qui ont
probablement dépasser un petit peu le
contexte où ils sont autorisés dans le
rapprochement dans le nombre de
personnes ils ce sont des foyers les
mimiques lost qui se sont formés ainsi à
différents endroits il faut donc éviter
maintenant qu'il contamine plus
largement la population autour d'eux on
l'a dire la belgique un mauvais bilan en
termes de vols ar rapport habitants
contamination est victime
à quoi vous attribuer cela on va un
petit peu dans le passé effectivement
avant ces restrictions mais comment vous
expliquer ce mauvais bilan d' du pays
on avait bien discuté ensemble ce point
il ya quelques temps le pays a
comptabilisé cdc de manière différente
que d'autres pays on a comptabilisé tous
les décès compatit
le même nom prouver que vite positif
tout spécialement dans les maisons de
repos on a eu des problèmes en maison de
repos comme d'autres pays effectivement
dans différentes parties du monde et
ceci nous amène un bilan qui est
correspond parfaitement à la
surmortalité que nous avions pendant ces
quelques mois on n'a pas su ou
sous-estimé au surestimé pardon
au contraire notre pays qui ont parfois
sous-estimé de 40 à 50% la mentalité
covit aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
tout le matériel nécessaire pour faire
face on sait que comme en france la
belgique a certainement manqué de
masques et de tests au début est ce que
c'est encore le cas non maintenant nous
avons largement la capacité de tester
entre 35 et 45
il teste par jour il y a des centaines
de millions de masques enfin 100
millions de masques déjà disponible
bientôt 200 millions de masques plus de
30 millions de cfp deux et on a
largement le matériel disponible pour
assumer une deuxième vague mais nous ne
sommes pas à la deuxième fois qu il faut
tout fait pour l'éviter justement est ce
que vous voulez à craignais en tant qu
infectiologues ont tout le monde la
crème et dont je pense que si on prend
les mesures adéquates et les mesures ont
été prises dans d'autres pays qui ont
connu ce genre un sursaut l'espagne par
exemple d'autres encore l'allemagne à
quelques temps elles ont pu montrer qu'
il ya moyen de 2,20 quo si on prend à
temps avec les bons moyens
toute chose qui n'avait pas été faite au
mois de mars ou fin février lorsque ni
les moyens ni la manière d'agir d'été
encore clairement déterminées pour vous
quelle est la priorité aujourd'hui terme
en ce sont les gestes barrière à tout à
fait non pas traitement commençaient le
vaccin faut donc attendre quelques mois
pour le geste marié reste aux essentiels
et surtout de la population prenne
conscience comme partout que le virus
est toujours là les vacances des faces
pas le virus peut fait on rencontre des
amis mes fesses pas le risque de
transmission est donc c'est la reprise
des bonnes manières de fonctionner qu'on
avait il ya quelques mois qu'on n'oublie
ferait rapidement pour soi même et
surtout pour protéger les autres qui
sont plus fragiles
éventuellement on parlait de cette
cérémonie ces festivités en belgique une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
pour la cérémonie
c'est quelque chose d'inconscient pour
vous aujourd'hui de se rassembler où
finalement on peut se rassembler avec
une centaine de personnes tout en
respectant des gestes barrières en plein
air notamment et ça ne doit pas poser de
problème dont je pense qu'il ya pas de
problème à l'endroit où il y avait une
centaine de personnes y en a l'habitude
donc on est vingt fois moins dense que
d'habitude ces personnes étaient
amplement dispersé comme vous le dites
en plein air la foule n'était pas à lui
seul cette partie d'inviter une centaine
d'invités étaient étaient présents et
donc il n'y a aucun risque et pas les
dizaines de milliers personnes au
minimum présente le long du défilé comme
chaque année il n'y avait pas défilé
donc il n'y avait pas trop population
pour vous c'est vraiment les espaces
confinés qui reste le principal danger
le plein air est une forme de garantie
ou c'est peut-être un peu osé de dire
cela c'est aux clauses et en même temps
c'est vrai le plein air est une forte
diminution en tout cas du risque puisque
on disperse ses éventuelles particules
virales c'est à l'intérieur que le
problème va se poser ce n'est pas pour
rien que en belgique d'abord en france
récemment dans des lieux confinés
l'intérieur magasins et autres
administrations
le port du masque est rendue obligatoire
et que la ventilation heureusement plus
facile en été qu'en hiver est amplement
recommandé pour disperser des particules
éventuellement présentes dans l'air donc
des fenêtres grandes ouvertes ça reste
très efficace selon vous en tout cas une
bonne ventilation n'ont pas forcément de
grands courants d une bonne ventilation
à nombre de personnes pour l'aliment
réduit pas trop denses et le port du
masque si nécessaire sont des gestes
avec la distance iman sociale et le
lavage des mains qui doit permettre de
refroidir justement les endroits où le
virus s'est représenté depuis quelques
temps merci beaucoup il va vendre les
thèmes d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france